[Musica]
solo l'imprenditore dall'età di
vent'anni
diciamo che sono stato uno start upper
senza saperlo senza sapere di esserlo
nel 1980 non era in voga il concetto
dello start upper soprattutto in val di
sangro
e sola persona fortunata
perché
le mie passioni sono l'innovazione
quindi scienza tecnologia quello che c'è
dietro quello che consente l'innovazione
ma anche appassionato di natura
come nicola fossaceca condivido il che
c'era insomma di stare a contatto con la
natura tutto ciò normalmente insomma fa
bene alla mia anima fa bene alla mia
voglia in qualche maniera di fare e
in qualche maniera la
sostenibilità che oggi abbiamo sentito
più volte nominare qualche volta anche
con il concetto di green washing che
significa insomma andarsi
a farsi un make up insomma aggiustarsi
in qualche maniera per apparire ai più
belli di quelli che si è è un qualcosa
che appartiene alla mia operatività
perché quando ero ragazzo e andavo a
scuola non sa basta ma a lanciano
protestavamo per le strade
perché non volevamo la sangro chimica
che era un potenziale insediamento
industriale in val di sangro
sempre quando ero ragazzo è successo un
incidente a seveso
oggi la legge europea che parla della
sicurezza si fa riferimento al nome di
questa città dove c'era l'impianto
produttivo che ha avuto l'incidente e
qui alle mie spalle ho questa immagine
non molto evocativa per un evento del
genere però era la cruda realtà e bhopal
che una città indiana dove per lo
scoppio di questa fabbrica qui sono
morte 4 mila persone e decine di
migliaia di persone hanno avuto problemi
di salute molto seri per cui mi sono
occupato di sostenibilità non perché
allora attirasse l'attenzione
dell'amministratore delegato di black
rock
ma perché lo pensavo fosse un dovere
a 20 anni non era un padre di famiglia
ma ho pensato che era il caso di
comportarsi da buon padre di famiglia
per cui ripeto è stato un aspetto molto
importante nella nella nel nel dna nel
costruire il progetto imprenditoriale e
che oggi è diventata una bella realtà e
bisogna fare sostenibilità non soltanto
nella maniera in cui si produce i propri
prodotti ma la sostenibilità è
importante anche per quello che i tuoi
prodotti possono fare presso i propri
clienti
il cibo lo abbiamo già in qualche
maniera
evocato in maniera molto più
qualitativa e attrattiva di quanto in
questo momento farò io
e
il cibo è stato un problema per
l'umanità per molti secoli e noi siamo
probabilmente le prime due tre
generazioni che non hanno sofferto la
fame
ancora oggi nel mondo ci sono 800
milioni di persone che soffrono la fame
normalmente non lo consideriamo questo
aspetto perché ovviamente siamo nella
parte
fortunata per cui l'obiettivo per molti
secoli è stato produrre cibo a
sufficienza e tutte le persone che hanno
operato nel mondo della agricoltura
hanno dato un contributo importante in
questa direzione qui
siamo riusciti a
sconfessare la teoria del di un abate
malthus che nel 1800 diceva che la
crescita della popolazione mondiale
sarebbe stata limitata dalla
disponibilità di cibo
oggi diamo da mangiare a 7 miliardi di
persone
ma oggi non ci si chiede soltanto di
produrre cibo a sufficienza ci si chiede
anche di produrre cibo di qualità e
sappiamo che un cibo di qualità aiuta la
nostra salute
che sappiamo da un po di tempo che la
maniera in cui il cibo viene prodotto
può impattare
in maniera più o meno importante nella
salute del nostro pianeta
oggi siamo molto concentrati sul
problema del covip giustamente
siamo preoccupati della recessione
economica che si purtroppo è latente
viene alcuni casi in altri è molto
evidente
cominciamo finalmente a parlare dei
cambiamenti climatici
vi ricordo che fino a pochi anni fa che
era questa sconosciuta
abbiamo altre emergenze di cui dobbiamo
preoccuparci
ad esempio quella della salute del suolo
nell'essere orgoglioso fiero di
appartenere ad un comparto industriale
che riesce da a dare da mangiare a 7
miliardi di persone devo dire che siamo
però responsabili anche di circa un
quarto delle emissioni di co2 e tanti
altri impatti negativi che in virtù
dell'agricoltura in qualche maniera poi
noi ci ritroviamo come effetto
secondario
siccome mi piace sempre guardare in
qualche maniera
in avanti
e
ho mantenuto la capacità di sognare o di
immaginare il futuro o di essere
attratto al sogno alla l'immaginazione
spesso
essendo appassionato di tecnologia
spesso immagino come sarà
la mobilità nei prossimi anni
abbiamo già alcune evidenze come sarà la
produzione di energia la gestione
dell'acqua e
non so voi ma non immagino che quando
andremo a spostarci da un posto ad un
altro lo faremo con i cavalli
se c'è qualcuno in sala che lo immagino
ci deve essere mia figlia in fondo non
c'è perché una bambina che è
appassionato di cavalli ma non c'è
quando parliamo di agricoltura
direi quasi
stranamente
spesso invece ci perdiamo nel
romanticismo
ed è bellissimo ma vi posso assicurare
che dare da mangiare a 7 miliardi di
persone
e ad una popolazione crescente e ad una
classe media crescente che quindi non si
accontenta più di mangiare un piatto di
riso ma vuoi mangiare anch'essa il pollo
piuttosto che fa carne inevitabilmente
purtroppo l'agricoltura biologica non è
la risposta alle esigenze di nutrire il
pianeta più il futuro è una scelta
rispettabilissima va bene farla a casa
la faccio anch'io ma non è più sana di
quanto non lo sia l'agricoltura
convenzionale
non c'è né un unico studio scientifico
che dimostri questo
l'abbiamo avuto l'agricoltura biologica
50 anni fa e la produzione era la metà
di quella di oggi per cui non riusciremo
a sfamare il
bisogno che abbiamo oggi ancora meno di
altre due miliardi di persone che
arriveranno su questo pianeta
da qui nei prossimi decenni e
soprattutto
avendo una produttività più ridotta non
è più sostenibile perché avremmo bisogno
di più superfici agricole per poter
produrre cibo a sufficienza e siccome
abbiamo già
disboscato la foresta amazzonica
non ne abbiamo molte altre di foreste da
da da da abbattere
questa è l'agricoltura del futuro che io
immagino
ed è un'agricoltura fatta di tecnologia
di drone di sensori di dati di
intelligenza artificiale dove mentre
oggi quando vedete un trattore entrare
in un campo e vedete un nuvolone di
prodotto che si spruzza dappertutto a
potremmo avere la possibilità di
spruzzare soltanto su una parte della
pianta in maniera precisa in maniera
efficace in maniera efficace per
garantire
cibo a sufficienza e utilizzare meno
input e che possa essere più sostenibile
qui ci sono un po di dati ma vista l'ora
e
la specificità del tema
le prime due
primi due parametri che prime due barre
si riferiscono all'impatto di emissione
dell'agricoltura in termini di co2 e la
barra gialla e quanto questa potrà
diventare da qui al 2050 in termini
emissioni se non
diventiamo più efficaci se non
adottiamo pratiche che riescono
praticamente a ad avere ad abbattere
l'impatto dell'attività agricola nel
mondo
una di queste
driver è sicuramente quella di aumentare
ancora di più la produttività
oggi abbiamo ancora un 70 per cento di
potenziale genetico che le piante hanno
e che noi non riusciamo a sfruttare
perché
perché le avversità che la pianta da
quando inizia il suo ciclo alla fine del
raccolto
perde perché troppo caldo troppo freddo
gli manca un nutriente gli manca l'acqua
e perde produttività quindi noi abbiamo
l'opportunità di incrementare la
produttività in maniera significativa
per fare questo però vi ripeto abbiamo
bisogno di scienza
è una sfida che non risolviamo soltanto
guardando ad un comparto ad esempio
all'agricoltura nonostante ripeto siamo
responsabili importanti è una sfida che
risolviamo anche essendo cittadini più
responsabili
in italia sprechiamo cibo per che
potrebbe bastare dare da mangiare a 40
milioni di persone
l'acqua
vorrei che un giorno riuscissimo a bere
l'acqua del nostro rubinetto
e divento letteralmente matto quando in
un ristorante a san francisco
sul mio tavolo mi trovo l'acqua minerale
che viene dalle nostre alpi perché non
bere l'acqua minerale che viene dalle
montagne rocciose
oppure e non è andare contro la
globalizzazione
è una semplice riflessione che voglio
fare con voi di come i vostri
comportamenti le cose che voi scegliete
di fare o di non fare poi sono dei
segnali importanti per un imprenditore
per chi fa in qualche maniera mette a
vostra disposizione prodotti e servizi
in qualche maniera sto toccando dei temi
che abbiamo già coperti la biodiversità
se perdiamo le api
scompariamo anche noi
non ci sarà cibo
perdiamo una quantità di biodiversità
nel mondo oggi animale e nel mondo
vegetale che è impressionante e anche lì
c'è un segnale di allarme molto
importante non possiamo trascurare
questi aspetti qui e lo dico per i
ragazzi
noi non siamo stati una buona
generazione non mi sento assolutamente
come dire orgoglioso di quello che
abbiamo fatto presente siamo una delle
generazioni che lascia un mondo peggiore
di quello che ha trovato non avendo
avuto una guerra o una calamita come
normalmente succedeva in passato
il pil
la salute del suolo diamo per scontato
il suolo e lì c'è ha nutrito per
secoli da sempre immaginiamo che sarà lì
per sempre
sul suolo
costruiamo le nostre case in passato nel
suolo riposavamo in maniera eterna e
definitiva in un cucchiaio
vivono più di un miliardo di
microorganismi se c'è
un biologo in sala spero possa
confermare e viene maltrattato lo stiamo
rendendo sterile la maniera in cui
facciamo agricoltura da decenni non
preserva per le prossime generazioni
la qualità del del suolo
abbiamo un'opportunità fantastica
i nostri politici se ne stanno
accorgendo se ne sono accorti anche
dal mondo della della finanza e ad
esempio in europa e il green deal ci dà
un'opportunità per allineare in qualche
maniera
gli obiettivi qualitativi per la nostra
vita futura
ma anche gli obiettivi economici
e qui voglio parlarvi
di una persona che ho molto a cuore che
sono i nostri clienti gli agricoltori
è una categoria
maltrattata è una categoria dove
non so se c'è qualcuno della mia età
probabilmente hai mai mi rendo conto che
non siamo in tanti in passato negli anni
settanta in emilia romagna se qualcuno
faceva l'agricoltore non trovava moglie
c'erano persone che partivano
dall'abruzzo e andavano e venivano
sposate più o meno consentitemi in
perché
e andava diventava moglie di un
agricoltore che nei dintorni solo per il
fatto che facesse l'agricoltore non
trovava praticamente la compagna di vita
bene la figura dell'agricoltore
non so se anche grazie alla pandemia
negli ultimi mesi o negli ultimi anni ne
sento parlare in maniera un po diversa
vi posso assicurare che è un mestiere
bellissimo che dà l'opportunità di stare
a contatto con la natura che ripeto per
quanto mi riguarda è un bene prezioso ma
è anche un mestiere che si farà
diversamente ed è anche un mestiere che
molto probabilmente in un futuro non
lontano riceverà il compenso non
soltanto per produrre i carciofi ma
anche perché in qualche maniera sarà
guardiano dell'ambiente e perché potrà
contribuire non all'emissione di co2 ma
a catturare le a co2 che di trattenerla
nel suolo
nel mio romanticismo
mi piace immaginare
spesso ogni tanto mi ci perdo e al
nostro pianeta terra
come la più grande astronave mai
costruita e che ci porta a spasso nei in
giro per il cosmo per l'universo vorrei
che la bellezza del nostro pianeta
venga preservata per le future
generazioni per i nostri figli ei figli
dei nostri figli e il momento di agire
per fare per garantire il futuro alle
prossime generazioni che adesso grazie
[Applauso]